une autre entreprise mais qui elles
marchent plutôt bien en ce moment la
snpe la société nationale des poudres et
explosifs de bergerac a doublé ses
effectifs en dix ans à la base de ce
succès les efforts commerciaux de
l'entreprise des efforts tourner vers le
civil la snpe a lieu placé sous haute
surveillance mais uniquement pour des
raisons de sécurité un reportage de ram
1go thérèse chantois lité
500 salariés en 1972 près de 11 cents
aujourd'hui l'ancienne société des
poudres a connu une véritable explosion
de ses effectifs au cours de ces
dernières années à l'origine du succès
la prospection du marché civil et la
percée d'un produit la nitrocellulose il
s'agit des fibres courtes du coton
soumise à l'effet du nitrate le taux
d'azoté mélangés par la suite donnera
soit des poudres soit des solvants à
usage civil puis la création de la
société en 1972 nous avons entrepris un
effort important de diversification vers
le secteur civil de façon à mieux
équilibrer nos productions et à limiter
les risques de récession cadre de
l'évolution des marchés des engins
militaires toujours comme ces douilles
combustible produite à plus de cent
mille exemplaires par an mais aussi des
basses pour vernis à ongles ou encore
des peintures et des encres toutes ces
productions bénéficie d'un secteur de
recherche bien implanté et
d'investissement régulier de l'ordre de
10% du chiffre d'affaires annuel à la
clé des emplois nouveaux nous avons créé
grâce à ce développement une centaine
d'emplois nous avons pu également
développer enfin maintenir et développer
nos ventes en y 3 cl aux industriels
malgré une récession mondiale importante
et dans un climat de concurrence
extrêmement ap et nous exportons
actuellement dans ce domaine 75 % de
notre production dans 60 pays
en 1982 dans le monde aujourd'hui le cap
des 1000 employés et dépassé donc
l'accroissement s'est fait en deux temps
1976 78 on frôle le millier avec la
faillite du principal concurrent
américain sur le marché des micro
cellulose retombé à 900 1980 enfin ces
deux dernières années l'ascension
reprend avec l'aide de la qatar les
départs en pré-retraite et les
réductions d'horaires à 36 heures sans
subvention de l'état avec un bilan
équilibré cette entreprise du secteur
semi public veut souffler aujourd'hui
ces structures ne lui permettent plus de
dépasser le seuil d'emploi atteint
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]